if I win you give them reaction channels
their talent back and if you win you get
me yep looks like I'm throwing this one
Hey
ladies and gentlemen looks like Space
Jam 2 with LeBron James is shaping up to
be the biggest cinematic crossover it's
ready play everyone my goodness this is
gonna be nuts oh I was just like going
on some movie news sites and I came
across this thing that I just thought
was a rumor but apparently there's
leaked footage some people thought the
images were fake and then they had an
actual b-roll showcasing a wide variety
of characters this comes courtesy from
the Instagram account DC u-verse yeah I
had this footage of what looked like Jim
Carrey's the mask Jared Leto as the
Joker also Pennywise the Joker so this
is Space Jam 2 and then they have this
footage I will play for you right here
it looks like yeah they'll be having the
Looney Tunes characters DC characters
The Wizard of Oz Harry Potter
potentially yeah like Voldemort is
rumoured to be in there there's rumor
drugs from yes Clockwork Orange and have
like the looks this movie for Batman's
rumored to be in here penguin Mad Max
Agent Smith agent matrix what WB gifted
like the lego movies it seems like
they're doing here in some ways I guess
is appropriate I guess they're just a
little bit jarring because you don't
expect it from Space Jam because Space
Jam was just Michael Jordan and Looney
Tunes and then this one is doing the
whole WB property I mean yeah lego movie
is WB but there's something about it
that I have an easier time poking fun at
themselves because Lego already
encompasses as a brand of so many other
brands yeah I feel like that brings that
in whereas the first movie had a very
solid set of mash up since the Looney
Tunes world with the world of Michael
Jordan and the NBA yeah and now it seems
like yeah we're opening this up it seems
like what WB is trying to do which I
don't
altogether hate but I think is kind of
strange is they're they're developing
this universe where it literally is yeah
just all their characters live here and
you'll see different movies with
different moves worlds etc but where
they're all gonna cross over somehow so
like it you can dress it in different
skins which keeps it fresh but I'm very
curious as to how long this is gonna
keep up at the end of the day Space Jam
is gonna be a lot of it's gonna be an
animated movie so I could see why they
so might have had the thought of
whatever they're doing with lego movie
let's put it over here also though the
Space Jam audience space-time came out
of 96 and so a lot of us are a lot older
decades old right I think that's a fun
way to get the people who grew up on
Space Jam who now realize space chance
probably not that good of a movie yeah
hopefully and our give me that director
who did Space Jam that was the last
fictional feature film he ever did yeah
commercials a lot of documentaries and
stuff this is I think a good way to hook
people because of the people who are now
grown up are watching the movies like it
chapter two I don't think it's or
watching it I don't anything a little
kids really watch the Looney Tunes you
know it's even further established that
nostalgia poking fun at that fan craze
that we love with the crossovers
it sounded like super bizarre at first
it still is pretty bizarre the more I
think about it the more I think this
actually makes sense it could really
work and I really could be a whole lot
of fun to watch or it could end up
feeling like those Freiberg insults or
parody movies like disaster movie or
like hey look at that character or that
character those were the first real
crossover they were I don't want it to
feel like that if they can do an
embodiment cuz it looks like they got a
completely different person to play
Jared Leto's Joker and Jim Carrey is not
coming back for the mask but they want
to have them be in their likeness and
they have them show up and if they can
really embody it as opposed to just a
parody gimmick where they just say their
line or something I think they could do
something really cool with it and the
fact that it's from Warner Brothers
maybe they're something special to be
had here I mean it certainly seems as
though there's going to be more thought
and effort put into this Space Jam movie
than the first one at least in terms of
the story to prime mean the first movie
has a lot to appreciate in terms of the
collision of animation and live-action
but not in terms of plotting story
characters etc basically depends on how
much you like Michael Jordan and the
Looney Tunes and so this does make sense
because yeah Space Jam is from 96 you're
gonna have to hook the people who did
not grow up with that to whom it is just
a meme
and also the people who grew up with it
and do somehow care about the quality
it's like I like having the other
characters invade actually because
that's what the first movie in a
microwave was about was about fictional
characters clashing in with the real
world the fee that kind of always gets
me about these didn't bug me as much
with the ready player one because that
was aimed and an older audience but I
feel like Space Jam has to have a kid
accessible quality to it and so getting
again like these Clockwork Orange
characters and like you know villains
that are pretty violent and tacitly just
kind of makes me raise an eyebrow yeah
is a kids movie really prime place for
Pennywise and drugs and stuff at the
same time then it does open you up to a
wish list of other villains you like to
see yeah alright guys well what do you
think about the Space Jam 2 news who do
you want to see appear in this movie got
anyone in mind
sub-zero scorpion from Mortal Kombat ooh
how about Cujo or or or the flamethrower
man from Lethal Weapon 4 who that'd be
fun yeah leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click the notification bell
catch you guys soon